joe biden fue elegido formalmente como
candidato demócrata a la presidencia de
eeuu en la segunda jornada de convención
del partido el ex vicepresidente logró
el apoyo de 3.558 delegados aunque
quedaron evidenciadas divisiones al
interior del partido con discursos a
favor del ex virtual candidato bernie
sanders golpe de estado en mali el
presidente del país anunció su renuncia
luego de que un grupo de militares lo
detuviera los soldados presentaron un
comité nacional de salvación pública
anunciaron elecciones en un plazo
razonable
y los fanáticos del parís saint germain
celebraron anoche que su equipo llegó a
la final de la champions league por
primera vez luego de vencer a leipzig
tras el encuentro de hoy entre el
olympique de lyon y el bayern múnich
quedará definida en la final del domingo
ampliaremos desde lisboa
muy buenos días saludamos a la audiencia
de france 24 en español muchísimas
gracias por acompañarnos como siempre
soy santiago holística y comenzamos esta
emisión de noticias en eeuu y es que los
demócratas confirmaron a joe biden como
el candidato del partido para la
presidencia del país en una votación en
la que bardem se hizo con una victoria
esperada ya que era el único
precandidato que seguía en la carrera
electoral a pesar de eso no recibió el
apoyo de todos los delegados al
conseguir el voto de tres mil 558
delegados frente a los 1.151 que obtuvo
sanders una votación que muestra la
fuerza del ala progresista del partido
veamos el informe de álvaro cordero
joe biden será el candidato demócrata a
la casa blanca en la segunda noche de
esta convención poco habitual debido a
su formato virtual bailén recibió el
apoyo de la mayoría de su partido con el
objetivo de vencer a donald trump donald
trump dice que estamos liderando al
mundo bueno si somos la única economía
industrial que tiene una tasa de
desempleo triplicado en tiempos así la
oficina oval debería ser un centro de
comando en su lugar es un centro de
tormentas solamente hay caos pero no
todo el partido cerró filas en torno a
byd en los delegados más progresistas
dieron su apoyo a bernie sanders que
obtuvo mil 151 votos el ala más a la
izquierda del partido pudo demostrar así
su fuerza en su equipo en un momento en
el que millones de personas en eeuu
están buscando soluciones sistémicas al
desempleo a la falta de salud women and
white healthcare en el espíritu en el
espíritu del pueblo y desde el amor para
todas las personas
quiero nominar al senador bernard
sanders de vermont para ser el
presidente de eeuu de américa
tras la nominación la esposa del
candidato de un discurso
a la unidad hay algunos que quieren
decirnos que este país ya está dividido
que nuestras diferencias no se pueden
reconciliar no pero eso no es lo que yo
he visto en los últimos meses porque nos
estamos uniendo y tomándonos unos a
otros
encontrando la gracia y la piedad en
estos momentos que muchos dan por
sentado cuando internet
y hemos visto que las diferencias son
preciosas y nuestras igualdades
infinitas
muy hemos demostrado que el corazón de
esta nación aún está latiendo con coraje
craig el nuevo candidato tiene previsto
dar su discurso este jueves último día
de la convención
continuamos en eeuu porque el director
general de correos de este país anunció
que suspender a que va a suspender a los
recortes a la oficina postal hasta
después de las elecciones de noviembre
hablamos de una medida considerada por
muchos como una estrategia por parte de
la administración de donald trump para
dificultar el voto por correo de los
estadounidenses y es que el mandatario
ha promovido la idea de que este tipo de
voto genera fraude
vuelta atrás después del alboroto por
las acusaciones de intentar influir en
las elecciones de 2020 la oficina de
correos de eeuu ha revocado los
polémicos cambios que estos
manifestantes de atlanta reclaman que
podrían dificultar la votación por
correo
nuestro derecho a votar por correo está
siendo atacado y estamos en medio de una
pandemia
ha habido un feroz debate sobre la
financiación postal en eeuu con un
número récord de estadounidenses que
esperan votar por correo debido al cob y
19 los últimos meses el servicio postal
del país comenzó a aplicar lo que han
denominado medidas de reducción de
costos incluyendo la eliminación de
buzones la cancelación de entregas y el
cierre de centros de clasificación pero
el martes el director general de correos
lewis de joe anunció que los cambios han
sido suspendidos hasta después de las
elecciones de noviembre para evitar
incluso la aparición de cualquier
impacto en el correo electoral el
movimiento viene después de una protesta
de los demócratas y una advertencia de
20 estados que se preparaban para
demandar a pesar del giro de 180 grados
la presidenta de la cámara de
representantes nancy pelosi sigue
adelante con la votación para evitar
cambios en el correo postal en el año
electoral
quieren detener esto porque elimina los
obstáculos de participación de la
votación y tienen miedo del votante
tiene un miedo del pueblo americano
porque porque la gente está sobre ellos
donald trump ha afirmado repetidamente
sin pruebas que un aumento de los votos
por correo conduciría a un mayor fraude
el voto por correo está muy extendido
entre los estadounidenses incluyendo al
propio mandatario que votó por correo en
las primarias de marzo y en las
elecciones intermedias de 2018
continuamos ahora con información acerca
del avance del coronavirus kobe 19 en
américa latina con más de 3.400.000
contagiados brasil se mantiene como el
país más afectado de la región seguido
por perú con casi 550.000 y mexico que
acumula 532 mil 239 argetina por su
parte superó la barrera de los 300.000
casos positivos en medio de una nueva
extensión del aislamiento social
obligatorio en este contexto la
organización panamericana de la salud
instó a los gobiernos de la región a
considerar a la salud mental como un
elemento fundamental en su respuesta
frente a la pandemia
y el expresidente de colombia álvaro
uribe renunció a su escaño en el senado
dos semanas después de que la corte
suprema de justicia ordenara su
detención preventiva para evitar que
pueda interferir en el proceso en su
contra por presunto fraude procesal y
manipulación de testigos una vida
política de más de dos décadas que llega
a su fin aurora balliu tienen más
detalles
tal vez el político que genera más
divisiones en colombia álvaro uribe ha
conseguido la unanimidad con 82 votos
por el sí y 12 por el no el senado
colombiano aceptó este martes la
renuncia del ex presidente a su escaño
el trámite llegó menos de una hora
después de que el ex mandatario
anunciara su decisión de abandonar el
congreso en este anuncio uribe expresó
su apoyo a una reforma judicial
propuesta por su partido centro
democrático y que ha ganado fuerza en
medio de su juicio hago votos por una
reforma a la justicia que la despolitice
al cambiar el sistema de elección de
magistrados
esto deberían llegar a la alta corte
general madura
que haya disuelto las vanidades y
afianzado el apego a la rectitud su
renuncia se dio en medio de la
investigación en su contra por la corte
suprema de justicia por supuesta
manipulación de testigos en la cual fue
ordenada su detención domiciliaria el
anuncio había sido recibido como una
bomba política en el país presidente de
2002 a 2010 senador desde 2014
incansable detractor del acuerdo de paz
firmado con la guerrilla en 2016
álvaro uribe es también el padrino
político del actual jefe de estado y
bando que tuvo el gran honor de trabajar
con álvaro uribe vélez en el senado soy
testigo de su amor por colombia su
entrega por los más vulnerables y su
compromiso por construir un mejor país
con su renuncia pierde el congreso- uno
de los mejores legisladores pero su
legado será imborrable en su anuncio
uribe también denunció que las garantías
procesales habían sido violadas durante
su arresto domiciliario y que las
escuchas telefónicas que forman parte
del caso eran ilegales
ya comenzó en bruselas la cumbre de los
líderes de la unión europea para abordar
la crisis en belarús sacudido hace ya
una semana por masivas manifestaciones
que exigen la renuncia del presidente
alexander lukashenko reelecto en unos
comicios tildados de fraudulentos las
naciones se evalúan incluso imponer
sanciones a minsk el encuentro se
produce horas después de que la
candidata opositora es la eterna hija no
obsta instar a los líderes europeos a no
reconocer los resultados de los comicios
en las elecciones del 9 de agosto no
fueron ni justas y transparentes pero
los resultados fueron falsificados
tiempo joven la gente salió a defender
su voto en las calles en las ciudades
alrededor de belarús
fueron brutalmente golpeados
encarcelados y torturados por el régimen
que se aferra desesperadamente al poder
de klínger montt paula
cientos resultaron heridos al menos dos
personas perdieron la vida
y esto está ocurriendo ahora mismo en el
centro de europa
y les pido que no se reconozcan esas
elecciones fraudulentas
y el presidente de mali y brain bubacar
keita anunció su renuncia luego de que
un grupo de militares lo detuviera junto
a otros altos funcionarios en medio de
un golpe de estado
los soldados presentaron un comité
nacional de salvación pública y
anunciaron además elecciones en un plazo
razonable de los hechos fueron
condenados por la unión europea el
consejo de seguridad de naciones unidas
anunció una reunión extraordinaria para
analizar la situación
a través de la televisión nacional el
presidente de mali brain bubacar keita
anunció su renuncia un giro en la crisis
política del país y eleva la
incertidumbre sobre el destino en la
nación africana
[Música]
la inversión del pueblo valía
quisiera en este momento agradecer al
pueblo maliense por su apoyo y
acompañarme durante estos últimos años
y un día decidió
y he decidido renunciar a mis funciones
de manera inmediata esto también
significa que el gobierno y la asamblea
nacional se disolverán
proyecto que consideramos
[Música]
la distribución de la asamblea nacional
es el de la emisión de keita llega
después que un grupo de militares lo
detuviera junto a otros funcionarios
entre ellos el ministro de finanzas y el
primer ministro de la nación miles de
personas se aglomeraron en la plaza de
la independencia de bamako para expresar
su apoyo a los militares todo el pueblo
de malí estaba esperando este día todo
el pueblo de malí estaba esperando que
calla magán y sus hombres al menos nos
dejaran respirar lo alto del yate liberó
al sur todo mal y ha sido liberado por
una fuerza republicana el pueblo de malí
los apoya estamos felices no hay
educación no hay salud no hay seguridad
se le ha dicho y no quiere escuchar a su
gente
el levantamiento genera un cambio en un
país afectado desde hace dos meses por
protestas contra el gobierno los
manifestantes exigían la renuncia de
keita a quien responsabilizan de una
economía estancada la corrupción en el
gobierno y una insurgencia yihadista
pasamos ahora con información deportiva
los fanáticos del parís saint germain
celebraron anoche que su equipo llegó a
la final de la champions league por
primera vez tras vencer por 3 a 0 a los
alemanes del lives y que el partido se
disputó en lisboa portugal y allí
precisamente se encuentra natalia ruiz
periodista de france 24 o la natalidad
bueno hablemos primero de lo más
destacado de la noche de ayer
así después hubo muchísima fiesta sobre
todo en las calles del centro de lisboa
porque ustedes saben los o partidos se
juegan sin un público por causa de la
corona vídeos así que los cientos de
parisinos que están aquí en a lisboa
festejaron y luego pues llevaron toda
esa fiesta al hotel del parís a sandra
amaya dicen algunos unos astados unos
200 aparecidos que esperaron el regreso
de su equipo de sus héroes que como
ustedes bien lo decía pues se
clasificaron a la final de la liga de
campeones por primera vez en sus 50 años
de historia y ahora pues están esperando
saber quién va a ser ese contrincante
que tendrán en el estadio andaluz en
este próximo domingo en esta final tan
esperada para parís y sobre todo para
los qataríes detrás del equipo que han
hecho una gran inversión para llegar
hasta aquí mejor nada casi histórica por
lo que cuentas para los fanáticos del
parís saint germain natalia que se
espera del partido de esta noche que se
va a disputar entre el bayern múnich y
el olympique de lyon
así después es la otra semifinal que
también es franco-alemana estos dos
equipos ya se han enfrentado al menos
nueve veces en liga de campeones y pues
siempre digamos que es el bayern munich
quien ha sacado provecho de esto el
bayern munich espera tener de nuevo el
título de campeones de europa algo que
no consiguen desde 2013 pero el
anfitrión ha hecho una gran campaña en
esta liga de campeones llegando hasta la
hasta la semifinal en octavos eliminó a
la juventus de turín en cuartos eliminó
al manchester city- de pep guardiola así
que viene con muchísima fuerza y pues el
bayern munich ustedes saben vino como
una máquina de matar y le dio esa
goleada al barcelona en cuartos de final
así que vamos a ver si este domingo será
una final completamente francesa o una
final franco-alemana estaremos muy
pendientes natalia de lo que suceda en
la semifinal de hoy en la final del
domingo por supuesto muchísimas gracias
por este reporte desde portugal a
nuestra audiencia quédense con nosotros
hay mucho más en france 24 y como
siempre les decimos en nuestra página
web
france24 punto com
[Música]